i've had a question in my mind that's
been haunting me uh-huh okay
this guy
came out of the toilet right right in
the public toilet and he flushed the
toilet as he left when do you flush the
toilet
uh because i do you do you like cause
yeah well it depends what you're doing
you've done it you've done a number two
right okay number two right yep you have
your you know so you stand up right
you now have two options you can start
buckling your belt putting it back up
putting you know getting that already or
you can flush the toilet which one you
do first while standing up
yeah because there are some people who
flush while they see that that ain't
right that is
that's
just typhooning your [ __ ] of [ __ ]
water like that's terrible the only
circumstance upon which you are allowed
and i will i will i will give the pass
to be able to flush the toilet while
still sitting on it yes you know that
smell is so goddamn bad that you your
cheeks are the only thing keeping it in
here okay i personally stand up first
when i flush you no no obviously yeah
because you're you're a human being yeah
i'm not do you then right so let's say
you've unbuckled right your pants
because you obviously you've run back
with them i don't know why this has been
burning on my mind because this men did
it he clearly right
he clearly got up did his pants and then
flushed the toilet and left
right yeah
which one do you do first because
sometimes i immediately i just close the
thing flush and then start doing up my
pants i why is that i buckle up my pants
first i buckle up my pants first then
flush them yeah yeah yeah why am i the
weird one what happened in my childhood
because it's like it's weird like the
way you do it is weird because it's that
means you're literally standing there
flushing the toilet with your pants down
so like i'm like this right pants are
here i'll i'll simulate it i'll simulate
it okay
so it's like this right yeah right i'm
like okay close the lid flush and then i
do this while it's flashing but your
pants are down all right
no well then that's the exact same thing
right when i'm like this right right i
come up and then as i'm getting up i
kind of like pull it up
to the point of like like it's there but
i just got to zip it up and do the belt
you know you understand what i mean you
understand what i mean right no
i don't i don't i fail to see the
difference
what's the difference what do you mean
like what's the difference between the
way you do it the way i do it so so when
i stand up i love how conversations got
[ __ ] already i just i just saw this
happening we just we just had like the
deepest [ __ ] therapy session
how do you flush your [ __ ] this has been
on my mind for like three days ago i saw
someone do it i'm gonna need a therapy
session off this conversation right so
so i stand up right
and i picture it right anyone with any
pants is doing this you pull it up right
yeah now there is a moment where you can
now decide to well your pants up you're
standing up your hands are now free for
a moment you can choose to then move
your hands to the zipper and the belt to
fully close your pants uh-huh or you can
flush the toilet okay i choose to i
choose to flush oh i choose to do my
pants first yeah
yeah like how do we how do we develop
these behaviors that's what i want to
know what makes us why do we why do we
do this it ain't that deep bro it's not
it's it's illegal
it's because i would like before i flush
the flush right is
the is is the signal that i have
finished everything yeah like because
because here's the thing here's the
thing right you sometimes sometimes
you're in a public toilet right i
[ __ ] hate the people who like flush
like sometimes sometimes you're [ __ ]
desperate you're just like god i need to
go [ __ ] now and you're waiting you're
waiting for something to come out of the
toilets and hear the flush
right hear the flush are you just like
all right they're coming out and they
stay in there for another five [ __ ]
minutes doing god knows what you're like
the flush is like the flash is like a
pavlova enough yeah
it's like you hear the flush it's all
ready to shift yeah yeah and it just
doesn't happen it's just it's just like
if you flush you better be coming out of
that toilet though you okay you better
if you flush there must be a 10 second
window you have to get out the toilet
yeah you're signaling the end of your
yeah that's why i want to be fully ready
to get out the moment i fly sort of
[ __ ] sprint man like i don't want to
keep the guy waiting i'm just wondering
is there something in my in my brain
that makes me decide to do that first
you're just trolling aren't you i don't
know like i do wonder this yeah
i'm going to take my entire
like little things i do and i wonder
like why do i do like that why do i do
those things i don't know maybe it's
like a maybe it's a habit you had since
you were a kid maybe yeah like maybe
when did you notice this in the first
place yeah
i noticed that this guy immediately left
after he flushed and i thought to myself
oh hold on i do like to flush and then
take a moment and just kind of oh you're
the one person i would [ __ ] hate to
be yeah
you are that [ __ ] who's like the
total 25 minutes the total time doesn't
change right but the perception of time
changes exactly i don't know if to you
it's 10 seconds after you've flushed it
to us it's 10 minutes but overall it's
the same time i'm spending in there so
it doesn't matter you're gonna get in
there so to me to me if you don't leave
the toilet by the time the flush is
finished then you are taking too long
yeah
that is the ethical right that is that
is the etiquette i agree right okay do
you also have we covered this on channel
before i don't know if we have how do
you poop in public bathrooms do you care
about that i mean
we haven't remember in school i was i
was the weird one because i didn't mind
pooping in the toilets but i also was
like what am i gonna do you [ __ ]
animal yeah like like to me to me it is
like a last resort
toilet
yeah i've seen crime scenes less messy
though
one thing i do remember now that we're
talking about this
when i was back in uh london
i went to i needed the tournament before
i got on my train in houston station
yeah one thing about houston station in
london is that it's probably one of the
dirtier train stations i'd say yeah it's
definitely one of the the rougher
looking stations it doesn't look as nice
as the train stations aren't already
dirty well i mean king's cross is pretty
nice um it looks pretty fancy
i'd say i know one thing one thing i
noticed after going back was like
compared to japan everything's done
train stations
yeah yeah you don't find out what
platform your train is on in houston
until like five minutes before yeah so
everyone's just standing there and then
when the thing comes up everyone's
rushing okay and it's like why don't you
just tell me it before and then but i
guess there's some system on their end
where they don't know yeah
it's stupid they should know they should
figure this [ __ ] out come on figure it
out [ __ ] figure it out um but so i
went to the toilet in houston station
and this ship was absolute war crimes
i'm sure some geneva conventions were
broken in this toilet yeah there was no
no toilet seat
in this toilet
this was just the ball it was just the
ball
i've seen that before and i thought
there must be a mistake that's already
nice
i refused to go in this one it was very
busy someone steal the lid or something
who knows
um
i go to the next one it's the same thing
i go to the next one and then now there
is now there is a toilet seat there it
is
but there is like
it is it is like something has happened
in here yeah not only is the smell
abhorrent but like there is like four
pieces of toilet tissue left and it's
that horrible horrible system of like
one tissue that they ration out that you
have to like you have to pull out 50 to
get one wipe with anyway it's like
what's wrong with you people i get it
that you don't need to take a [ __ ]
another role i understand that but why
do you have to make it such a small
amount you know what i mean like and
it's always like half a ply yeah it's
like if i held this up i could see
through it and navigate perfectly in a
car in a car right so there's this
toilet seat oh it's terrible and then
not only that when you leave it i hate
when public bathrooms do this they don't
have any soap anywhere yeah no soap no
way to dry your hands and it's like are
you you're just telling me not to dr
you're not telling you're just asking me
not to wash my hands yeah yeah right
like so i go there i do the obligatory
put water on my hands and leave and i
feel dirty still my hands are wet i
can't drive that's like i'm depressed
not only was there [ __ ] stains all over
this thing that stunk yeah it's terrible
shocking how do they not keep these
toilets clean i don't understand it's
just not getting paid enough are they
you have one job
and it's literally to keep them clean i
don't think there's anything else you
need to do
in the toilets well the thing is like
that's why i don't [ __ ] in public you
know that
this is why
yeah
i mean it's it's there is a big
difference between the toilets the
toilets
the toilets in japan versus the toilets
in the uk right i mean i mean as as you
mentioned last week the first thing you
noticed is a lot of things are a lot
dirtier in the uk well after you've been
living in japan for like this long right
yeah oh oh okay i haven't remembered
another story
go for it go for it sorry i i went to
this toilet in covent garden yeah so i
went to a coffee shop right coffee shop
was too small didn't have their own
toilet so they used a toilet uh in
coffin garden that was connected to the
church okay and it was
30 pence to enter it's about 50 cents
maybe yeah and um
oh that's right you guys charge for
toilets oh god this toilet was it was
like it was like entering some
uh sewer level on a video game going
down these stairs so it was in the
stairs down used to go on the street
level you have to go down this really
old looking 1800s architecture you get
to this this this out like this um kind
of cove looking thing it's just it's
this archway right and again it looks
like from something out of the 1800s
that was never replaced yeah yes it's
amazing great architecture woo yeah but
this is then this is turn style and it
is is the most disgusting color of
orange green
wall that you've ever seen and the
lights are flickering and uh yeah sounds
like you're about to enter a dark souls
level and i'm near certain i'm the only
person on earth who actually paid to get
in yeah because the moment i got it
jumped the turtle the moment i got in
two guys just jumped after me yeah so i
go in here right
and only one of the stalls is open
uh-huh so i go in there and i need to do
my business now unfortunately there was
only like two sheets of toilet roll left
so i was already it was already a bad
time hard mode time and there was no
bidet
obviously tragedy so my ass never quite
felt clean so i was constantly i was
also struggling with that every single
day yeah i definitely felt my ass was
not clean
they're genuine you joke but i i walked
around many days thinking like holy [ __ ]
i need to bring a portable today yeah
yeah um so i'm in this thing right
i'm hearing noises from the two stalls
and i'm like that's not a big deal it's
not a big deal and then this guy drops a
can that kind of ominously rolls into my
store right and it's a kind of guinness
and i kind of like kick it back and i'm
like here you go he's like cheers and
i'm like
and i'm like
okay
and he's like it's a nice day today in
it
and i'm like
you talking to me
i'm in the middle of the [ __ ] like
me he's like who else would i be talking
to and i'm like i don't know i'm like
why what i'm just confused i'm like yeah
yeah it's nice so i go out
and these two guys come out one of
them's homeless and one of them just
looks like i don't know who this guy is
he doesn't look homeless yeah but one of
the other guys is clearly homeless
because his stall
was just had his like sleeping bag in it
oh jesus and i was like what on earth is
going on and the guy was like you didn't
actually pay for it did you and i was
like yeah i did and he was like oh
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then washed his hands and left and
then the other guy just stared at me and
i was like this is the most
uncomfortable toilet experience i've had
a peep shot i thought i was gonna die
yeah and then i was like okay i'm just
going to go through and i just worked
the turd style which have to press like
some kind of emergency meeting
butterness to get out yeah horrible the
kicking back the guinness can just
sounds like an event in a game it was
weird this is how you activate the
why are you lying i heard something drop
and it had that really ominous noise of
rolling yeah yeah and it came over and i
was like
kicking it like
take it back i don't [ __ ] want your
guinness
it's a slight question yeah yeah
quest i'm just like what is this i
should want to take a [ __ ] jesus i mean
if there's one place i don't want to
have a conversation it's on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] right yeah especially not not
not you know maybe if we're in some kind
of ritz-carlton-esque toilet where it's
it's amazing hand towels you know what
yeah you know in a fancy place there's
no tissues there's towels there's a
towel there's a pile of towels to wash
your hands
and then i'm like actually how my day is
how is it i'm just enjoying the fine
selection of towels here soaps and
moisture milks you know that's great
that then talk to me yeah
but when we're in where i'm in the
sketchiest toilet in london no thank you
and there's a horrible stew next to you
i didn't know this guy had his whole
setup in there i was like oh my god
that's i mean like i don't know i don't
know if that's okay but i mean i'm glad
you're you've got some accommodation
yeah but like [ __ ] me jesus christ scary
yeah i just didn't know why they're
gonna call me a [ __ ] well i paid for
it i should be a good citizen you know
someone has to stock the toilet paper
how else they can afford it